est ce que eric zemmour est candidat no
est ce que eric zemmour appartient à un
parti qui justifierait qu'ils aient un
temps d'antenne no est ce que eric
zemmour a été condamné pour injure
raciale oui est-ce que ri eric zemmour
est un sexiste homophobe
révisionniste en un mot faciste oui et
pourtant figurez vous rien que le mois
de septembre c'est ce passage dans les
grands médias 4167 occurrence presse
vain une etc et quand on voit pas eric
zemmour matin midi soir etc eh bien on
en parle voilà y compris ceux qui
n'invite pas des rois de france inter
douze des trente cinq entretiens de
l'easa l'année donc non seulement on
parle beaucoup des risées mots non
seulement du coup on parle beaucoup des
thèmes d'eric zemmour qui sont loin
d'être les thèmes prioritaires des
français ils mettent chômage
problématiques sociales
environnementales mais en plus de ça
faut pas s'étonner dès lors vous parlez
des sondages que eric zemmour début
septembre par rapport au mois de juin
deux cités 7% des sondages fin septembre
un score à deux chiffres dès 15 % donc
voilà ce qui arrive et je pense qu'il ya
un jeu qui est très dangereux joué par
les médias dont à mon avis il ya
quelqu'un qui a bien préparé le terrain
ces macron puisque macron début 2020
qu'est ce qu'il raconte il fit le pays
légal pirée lp le pays réel cher à
moraski l'acier par ailleurs de
réhabiliter et il explique que
maintenant il va falloir qu'on parle
sécuritaire
immigration
islam et c'est ce qu'on a fait pendant
un an à l'assemblée nationale on a fait
que ça c'est ce qui a été fait sur les
médias et vous étonnez pas qu'après et
bien sur ce terreau pousse des émules
voilà ce qui se passe aujourd'hui il
serait peut-être temps que les médias
reviennent raisonnable et se rendre
compte qu'on est un peu dans les années
trop donnait la parole je vais donner la
parole à un nom mais ce que quelqu'un
qui sort de nulle part c'est à dire
qu'il n'est pas un professionnel de la
politique vous l'avez dit qu'il
représente à elle seule près nulle part
jamais dans son rôle du parent
politiquement accord il veut il
représente par une partie vous l'a dit
il est encore candidat or il est pour
l'instant d'après le dernier sondage il
est qualifié pour le 2e tour est souvent
c'est pas que ça justifie qu'on en parle
non je pense que je vous fais remarquer
que début septembre à l'orée du mois que
je viens de vous citer alors même qu'il
avait déjà une chaîne ces news pour pas
là cités qui faisait sa promotion à
longueur d'antenne il était qu'à 7 %
donc si vous pensez qu'il faut parler
parce qu'il est à 15% pourquoi début
septembre il était à 5 7% pourquoi on a
tout d'un coup parler sans arrêt des
mots moi ce que je crois c'est que c'est
le diable de confort de manon c'est
celui qu'il souhaite au deuxième tour en
face de lui parce qu'il dit que c'est le
plus facile à battre mais là encore au
fur et à mesure ses idées que j'ai
caractérise et alors je n'hésite pas de
que je canalise comme fasciste
malheureusement c'est quelque chose
qu'on entend de plus en plus fort et là
encore je m'adresse aux médias notamment
médias meanstream entre guillemets pour
dire qu'il faut peut-être arrêter nous
saturé l'espace à l'eczéma eric juste
serait dirigée par ont jugé ce prix
mentionné que vous enjoins vous avez mis
quarante secondes à prononcer le mot
fasciste dans cette émission est
normalement vous est vachement plus
rapide pour le faire maintenant vous
avoue que j'ai donné des éléments avant
melexis homophobe raciste mais si vous
voulez on va aller encore un peu plus
vite c'est pas comme si la réserve n'a
pas voulu me parler de votre journal
allez-y par les donjons à
une émission
j'observe que fasciste devient un nom un
peu galvaudé parce que fasciste non non
c'est pas mal boudé je me prends
cohérente et nevis
faty 5e mais ne faut pas limiter la
parole d'eric zemmour il ne faut pas
limiter la parole d'aï zemmour et je
m'étonne d'ailleurs de cette de cette
tribune de journalistes qui en gros nous
explique que le monde médiatique
journalistique se divise en deux
catégories ceux qui dans les
journalistes crèvent la dalle en quelque
sorte et sont obligés de parler de
zemmour parce que s'ils parlent pas de
zemmouri sont virés et les deuxièmes qui
contribuerait activement à la
propagation des idées d'eric zemmour
comme s'il s'agissait de créer un
frankenstein et d'alimenter le monstre
jeu la logique est quand même un peu
spécial parce que au nom du pluralisme
de la tolérance de la bienveillance de
l'humaniste de la démocratie eh bien on
retourne toutes ses vertus et toutes ces
valeurs contre elle-même pour censurer
quelqu'un de parler c'est exactement que
les comme les gens qui au nom de
l'antiracisme me traite par exemple de
sale arabe de service mais par humanisme
et bienveillance noir démocratie par
démocratie préciser votre propos les
journalistes décrivent eux-mêmes ces
jeux les sites comme respectueux des
valeurs démocratiques nommé d'accord
mais
euh il faut ses journalistes prétendant
prétendants fait nous combattent line
d'abord il faut il faut dire un truc
très évident à tout le monde sait que le
racisme l'homophobie le fascisme
l'antisémitisme sont interdits en france
donc déjà quelqu'un qui serait aux mots
font vertement homophobe ou ouvertement
racistes c'est interdit par la loi
d'accord ou antisémite c'est interdit
par la loi donc si maintenant on va
rentrer dans les normes et dans les
finasseries qui consiste à dire que si
par exemple on est contre l'immigration
massive qu'on dénonce le lien entre
certaines immigrations la criminalité et
la délinquance si ça c'est être raciste
et qu'on n'a pas le droit de le dire là
c'est autre chose dassault devient
politique ça ne vient pas légal quant à
la lutte contre la haine excusez moi si
vous voulez vraiment lutte lutter contre
la haine et si la lutte contre la haine
vous l'avez vous démange moi je
considère que la haine c'est celle des
racailles qui balancent des cocktails
molotov sur les flics pour tenter de les
immoler c'est là c'est la haine de ceux
qui traite de sale juif un français
israélite c'est la haine de ceux qui
traitent une femme de [ __ ] parce qu'elle
est légèrement vêtues dans certains
quartiers c'est la haine de ceux qui
font des rodéos qui empoisonnent la vie
des quartiers et qui risque la vie de
ses habitants c'est ça la véritable
cette haine là ne provient pas non c'est
loin
est ce que vous trouvez normal parce que
non mais non parce qu'il ya quand même
quelque chose qui est vrai c'est que on
a rarement vu une couverture médiatique
comme celles dont bénéficient en règle
ça faut le reconnaître ces familles mais
alors attendez moi je vous pensez que
c'est excessif je dis qu'il faut laisser
faire le jeu dit quelque chose de très
simple je pense que les médias par
exemple bfmtv bfm tv ou d'autres médias
mainstream sont comme assez peu suspecte
de faire le jeu des idées d'eric zemmour
comme si ces médias en parlent c'est
parce que effectivement ça intéresse les
gens dire comme j'entends monsieur
cochrane le faire que eric zemmour
serait une sorte de créature médiatique
qui n'existerait que parce que les
médias en parlent et que donc les mais
c'est les médias qui font réaliser moore
alors pourquoi les médias font pas pour
tous
pourquoi les médias font pas mélenchon
pourquoi les médias font pas hidalgo
c'est qu'en fait les gens tous ces
candidats l'aller la plupart des
français les vomis stocker en parler en
parler ça n'intéresse personne
voilà aujourd'hui celui qui est le plus
détesté dans tous les sondages par les
français cas le plus haut taux de cette
station c est oui mais la vie sauf si
c'est un cutter
c'est quoi encore
au classement et je quitte le talonne
s'il y allait de ce qui figure
emblématique du gilet jaune faut-il le
rappeler vous avez lancé en 2001 une
pétition contre eric zemmour qui
s'appelle eric zemmour xénophobe doit
être bannie des médias voilà un
programme qui a le mérite d'être clair
vous vouliez à alerter l'opinion
publique sur la dangerosité de ces
propos la pétition a recueilli cent dix
mille signatures alors au nom de quoi
voulez-vous c'est si j'ai bien compris
tu sais pas si c'est interdire et non
pas modérer la présence des règlements
oui bonsoir j'ai revenir rapidement sur
ce qu'a dit monsieur eric coquerel et
effectivement depuis la rentrée on est à
48 3% d'antenne cumulé pour les
règlements selon un chercheur clair sur
ce cas et si je le prononce pas mal son
nom si c'est le cas j'en excuse c'est
nous écoute et je vais prendre les
choses par un autre bout on a une ong
qui s'appelle destin commun qui a publié
un sondage avec l'institut kantar qui
révèle un certain nombre de choses ils
ont fait une étude sur 6000 personnes en
france qui a été publié cette étude a
été publiée en février 2020
qui révèle que 89% des français trouvent
le débat agressif trouve que dénonce les
faits répétitif le mauvais traitement de
l'information le traitement négatif de
l'actualité les effets de buzz les
effets de clash
et tout un tas de données qui viennent
selon ce panel a ajouté au pessimisme
ambiant chercha dépasse le cas du régime
non mais on y arrive j'ai rarement sujet
donc et du coup 62 % de ces personnes
dans ce sondage à trouve que climat
d'hostilité est assez
croissant à l'égard des personnes de la
population de confession musulmane donc
dire que les gens soient les amours et
ses faux déjà on a un sacré taux
d'abstention donc en fait et personnes
qui se disent soutenir les candidats qui
ont été affichées en réalité le parti
majoritaire en france est parti de
l'abstention qui n'est toujours pas
comptabilisé et reconnue comme étant
celui qui compte vraiment par ailleurs
et ensuite on a dans ce climat ambiant
est ce que les français considèrent
comme étant problématique on aussi à
côté de ça une crise sanitaire avec le
même traitement médiatique qui amène de
l'anxiété qui vient touché mentalement
selon les derniers sondage a été
effectué les dernières études des
chercheurs et a par dessus ça la crise
est venue interrompre un moment de
mouvement social intense contre la vie
chère en général et contre d'autres
injustices en particulier et qui va
s'accentuer avec les derniers les
dernières hausses de tarifs qu'on a pu
constater donc dans tout ce climat les
médias nous servent un personnage qui a
des propos qui viennent accentuer c'est
ce qui manque ce gène un personnage qui
encourage les comportements
discriminatoires à l'égard des personnes
qu'ils désignent qui vient accentuer
l'incitation le comportement
d'incitation à la haine et au rejet et
qui vient accentuer le sentiment de
crainte de coeur et oui ce sondage que
je vous cite il ne dit pas que ça il
parle aussi des coûts préoccupations des
français on a les sujets de pouvoir
d'achat on a effectivement l'immigration
mais la manière dont l'information est
traitée et la tribune qu'on donne à ce
type de personne qui traite les jeunes
délinquants mais c'est quand même un
délinquant multirécidiviste n'est ce pas
à qui on déroule en tapis rouge donc
j'ai envie de dire stop il a quand même
eu la parole un certain nombre de temps
l'idée on me dit souvent enfin les
personnes qui le soutiennent 10 c'est
quelqu'un qui a le droit à la liberté
d'expression la liberté d'expression
avait un cadre et un cadre légal
lorsqu'on s'amuse à déverser de la haine
partout et inciter les gens à détester
l'autre est à exclure l'autre ce n'est
pas la liberté d'expression ça n'entre
pas dans le cadre de la liberté lieu
d'allumer les juges nomme donc non je
suis en train jusqu'à lors ou dire qu'il
a été condamné pour des propos tantôt la
justice cij a tenté plus conventionnel
qui la laissez moi finir quand il a un
moment donné et puis tu s'éloigner de la
justice parce qu'il a fait j'ai relaxé
ou autres parce que justement il a pu un
moment donné se réajuster en utilisant
des propos des nuances et au lieu de
dire les les juifs il a dit des juifs au
lieu de dire les arabes et les noirs il
ya des bandes d'arabes et de noirs c'est
lui a permis de s'en sortir
néanmoins il ya un profil un profil qui
se dessine depuis ce n'est pas prouvé
qu'il est incertain mais mes problèmes
avec une certaine un certain type de la
population
on est en droit de se dire que c'est un
personnage qui apporte au climat en
fonction
je n'ai pas c'est juste la réalité ces
mots c'est de ne pas mettre les gens